كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك
يَا دَجَاجَاتِى يَا دَجَاجَاتِى
مَا أَحْلَاكِ مَا أَحْلَاكِ
كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك
يَا دَجَاجَاتِى يَا دَجَاجَاتِى
مَا أَحْلَاكِ مَا أَحْلَاكِ
كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك
كُلَّ صَبَاحٍ كاااك كاااك تَأْكُلُ وَتُرَدِّدُ كَاكْ كَاكْ
كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك   كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك
مَنْ قَالَتْ فِي القَنِّ كَاااكْ؟
ذَاتَ نَهَارٍ كاااك كاااك
قًدِمَ الثَّعْلَبْ كاااك كاااك
يَلْبَسُ صُوفَا كاااك كاااك
كَيْ يَخْدَعَكُمْ يَمْكُرُ يَكْذِبْ
كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك
كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك   كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك
مَنْ قَالَتْ فِي القَنِّ كَاااكْ؟
ظَلَّ الثَّعْلَبْ كاااك كاااك
ظَلَّ يُحَاوِلْ كاااك كاااك
كَيْ يَأْكُلَكُمْ كاااك كاااك
أَوْ يَأْكُلَ أَحَدَ الصِّيصَانْ
كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك
كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك    كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك
مَنْ قَالَتْ فِي القَنِّ كَاااكْ؟
وَدَجَاجَاتِي كااك كاااك
بِكُلِّ ذَكَاءٍ كاااك كاااك
كَشَفَتْ مَكْرَهْ كاااك كاااك
وَفَرَّ سَرِيعًا فِي ارْتِبَاكْ
كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك كاااك